[Music]
and the Brady Bunch house really made an
impression on Lance Bass never remember
them yeah he put a bid on it
but he didn't get it it didn't go his
way well now it's new owners hgtv may
have found a solution that'll make
everybody happy
sources tell et that the brass at HGTV
has reached out to Lance about working
together on the network's future project
at the iconic house
[Music]
as we've reported it was only the
exterior of the house that was shot for
the series the interior looks nothing
like the Brady Bunch house and was shot
on a Hollywood sound state I'm gonna
turn it into the TV house
Lance had already said that his original
hope was to gut the house and recreate
the Brady set inside and now HGTV has
told Lance and a tweet consider yourself
officially part of the HGTV Bunch
another pop star has put her house on
the market
Selena Gomez has listed her mansion for
just under three million at ten thousand
square feet it's in monserrate Texas
just west of where she was born I am
from Texas Grand Prairie Texas and I am
15 years old grown up now she could
afford amenities like a movie theater
game room and tennis court another of T
Swift's bad blood besties supermodel
Lily Aldridge is definitely hanging on
to her home welcome to my home she
showed her 7,000 square foot Nashville
home to Architectural Digest one of her
most prized possessions is a gift from
Taylor Lily played Frostbite in bad
blood and after it made video of the
year in 2015
swift made MTV Moonman for her girl
squad my Video Music Award very proud of
it never thought I'd get a moon man in
my life
you